[Music]
foreign
here are the 10 upcoming Kaiju flakes
that are currently under development
that are stated to be released this year
or early next year in 2024. let's get
into it the first one Godzilla zero on
Godzilla's 69th birthday the king of the
monsters will return to Cinemas this
time directed by Takashi yamazaki one of
Japan's most fascinating directors today
the unnamed 2023 Godzilla film announced
on November 3rd 2022 was planned to be
released exactly one year later on the
same day but 2023 and is expected to be
another monster flick of Epic
Proportions named by fans as Godzilla
zero this movie as from leaked images
will be set in the 1950s and it might be
a new origin story or at least a new
sequel to the original 1954 Godzilla
ignoring all other Touhou reboots
the second one Godzilla and the tyrants
another show focusing on the king of the
monsters Godzilla and the Titans will
feature again the most diverse Titan
apex predator immediately after his
fight against the mutos from 2014. Chris
black and Matt fractions Godzilla and
the Titans is one of the most
anticipated American monster television
series aside from stranger things the
series is meant to be a part of the most
diverse and as stated by creators will
feature all the Titans and also
introduce new ones into The Fray
number 3 gameri Rebirth this monstrous
Turtle Kaiju called Gamera isn't a part
of the Godzilla universe but has one of
his own with innumerable Kaiju both
small and gigantic gamero rebirth a
fresh new 6 episode anime series coming
soon to Netflix brings to Kaiju back to
life the official teaser was released
and hints that gamero will be
confronting 5 kaijus throughout the
course of the six episodes one of the
Kaiju will be his enemy called Gaius a
kind of like a Rodan kind of Kaiju there
will be four more and we hope this will
be Legion Iris zigra and goiron
number four the fourth Cloverfield movie
The clever monster might be the next
famous Kaiju that is going to be seen in
a part 4 movie of the Cloverfield
franchise which has now become sort of
like an anthology of loosely connected
storylines as of September 2022 the
Studios have finally settled on a script
and filming of this movie will start
early this year and the movie will most
probably be released next year in 2024
so we hope we are going to see the
dreaded lover Monster again as well as
new Kaiju that might fight it
number five Godzilla versus Kong the
sequel Godzilla vs Kong number two will
be the fifth movie for the legendary
monster verse the 38th film for the
Godzilla series of movies which includes
touhos and a 13 film for the King Kong
franchise it will be a sequel to GVK
2021 and is slated to be released on
March 15 2024. this movie will pit Kong
and Godzilla against a gigantic unknown
enemy hiding within our world
challenging all of our existence the
Epic new film will dive further into the
history of these Titans their beginnings
and the secrets of Skull Island and
Beyond revealing the exceptional
creatures and their Eternal bond with
Humanity
number six Kaiju number eight known in
English as Monster number eight this is
a very famous manga in Japan and
features quite a variety of Kaiju and
humans that are turned into monsters
themselves an anime television series
adaptation by production IG is in
production and is set to Premiere in
2024 so basically the story behind this
manga is that there are a lot of Kaiju
and monsters that are attacking Japan
and one of the Defenders of Japan gains
an ability to turn into one himself in
order to kill the other monsters
number 7 Hoshi 35 this is a crowdfunded
dokusatsu film a Kaiju flick that is
scheduled to be released in Japanese
theaters on October 2023 the premise is
as follows Aki a person finds herself
sharing a home with a newborn monster
and Leila became separated for unknown
reasons a large earthquake then strikes
Aki's residence 35 years later when the
shaking intensifies a massive creature
Looms in front of her this Kaiju is as
seen in the poster will be a hulky
monster that resembles Godzilla vaguely
by Design
number eight Skull Island this Netflix
animated series is still in the dark
even though it was announced way back in
2021 well the first image from the
series depicts two characters huddled in
the footprint of Kong and this was
posted by various Twitter accounts
including legendaries and Kong skull
Islands account on June 8 last year but
stayed in limbo ever since what we do
know however is that the creators are
finding their way around a general
storyline that will die in Kong with
other Titans and maybe adding Godzilla
into the fold
number nine the brush of the god this
film was crowdfunded by a motion Gallery
in September 2020 and has an anticipated
Autumn 2023 release date in Brush of the
god the storyline will mainly focus on
human characters and the Kaiju will be a
secondary element this next special
effects Kaiju film not produced by
Touhou is still one to keep an eye on
the film will include a number of huge
monsters including the 8th headed dragon
called Orochi yamata noorochi who looks
quite similar to Ghidorah but has eight
heads instead of three and also a lot of
legs and tales
and number 10 the lake this Kaiju movie
although released in Thailand last year
in the fall is yet to be released or
seen in other countries so I will count
this one in this list as well as it is
upcoming to us a tiny country girl
discovers a strange act in a field and
brings it to her hometown back home
suddenly a nine meter tall monster rises
from the water wreaking Devastation in
order to retrieve her egg the monster in
the lake was brought to life with
animatronics genuine life-size
animatronics coupled with CGI and even
though it's release it's still upcoming
to our movie screen so here it is at
number 10.
so I hope you have enjoyed watching this
video do hit that like button for
support and subscribe but most of all
smash that Bell icon for regular updates
on new videos right here on this channel
till the next one take care guys